ahí se encuentra nuestra enviada
especial a la novena cumbre de las
américas a natalia cabrera natalia la
salud o muy buenas madrugadas seguimos
amaneciendo para informarle a toda
nuestra audiencia directo américa lo que
ocurre en esta cumbre de las américas de
necesidad de los ángeles vamos a hablar
entonces natalia el anuncio que se
espera que haga hoy el presidente
anfitrión hablamos del estadounidense
joe biden esto materia de salud de
natalia
es raúl buenos días desde la ciudad de
los ángeles donde seguimos aquí
madrugando para directo américa con toda
la información
precisamente hoy es el tercer día de la
cumbre de las américas pero es el primer
día de el diálogo de alto nivel de las
sesiones plenarias de mandatarios y
jefes de estado del gobierno que asisten
aquí al centro de convenciones para esta
novena cumbre de las américas como lo
decía el presidente estadounidense joe
biden va a dar su discurso inaugural y
en él va a dar a conocer un plan de
salud para que la región se preparen
para futuras pandemias este plan este
programa pretende capacitar a alrededor
de 500.000 personas para que presten
atención médica especialmente en
territorios remotos y de esta manera que
la región que las américas estén mejor
preparadas para futuras pandemias y
eventuales pandemias
natale también se siguen conociendo
reacciones sobre el tema migratorio con
la nueva caravana de migrantes rumbo a
la unión americana
si raúl efectivamente el presidente joe
biden sigue tratando de mostrar de
alguna manera que continúa habiendo
avances a pesar de la ausencia de
grandes protagonistas o de los
principales actores de la migración en
el continente habló específicamente pues
del presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador quien como sabemos decidió
no asistir personalmente sino enviar a
su canciller en rechazo a la decisión de
la casa blanca en invitar a cuba-
venezuela ni a nicaragua tampoco está
presente la presidenta de honduras john
mara castró y por el momento no se han
hecho presentes ni el presidente de
guatemala que dijo que por problemas de
agenda no iba a venir a la ciudad de los
ángeles y por ahora el presidente en
aller bukele del salvador tampoco ha
llegado sin embargo la casa blanca sigue
diciendo que va a haber avances en
materia migratoria y le preguntamos
precisamente a una portavoz del
departamento de estado cristina rosales
que incluiría esta declaración final de
la cumbre de las américas de la novena
cumbre de las américas en esta materia
nos dijo por supuesto que aunque no
puede adelantarse a la declaración final
espera que si haya un acuerdo
en materia de ayudas económicas a los
países receptores de inmigrantes de
personas que siguen haciendo el tránsito
hacia el norte del continente pero para
que permanezcan en este país en un
tercer país seguro lo que se llama así
vamos a escuchar sus declaraciones para
france24 pues si se va a tratar en ese
pacto en esta declaración de unidad que
vamos a tener como ciertos países en
américa latina' obviamente a aquellos
que están
acoplando a muchos estos refugiados a
muchos estos migrantes cómo podemos
nosotros como eeuu económicamente
aportar y ayudar a que esos países
logren ayudar a entonces a los migrantes
a los refugiados que están haciendo su
proceso de su trámite para no solamente
quedarse en américa latina' en algún
otro país o también para aquellos que
están haciendo su trayectoria a eeuu
hoy el presidente de eeuu joe biden
entonces dará inicio con esta sesión
inaugural en el centro de convenciones y
por supuesto vamos a estar trayendo les
toda la información desde la ciudad de
los ángeles